so our good friend Luis J Gomez did you
see this him him with this heck I I when
I came in the lobby before the show this
was playing and I saw some of it I did I
don't know anything about this though
okay well he was at the stand
and he was on set and he had a Heckler
and that's all you need to know
my pictures these hot pictures are just
throwing their own thing look at her
she's ready to go
Joe Joe
they're hot leave him alone
let them let them be hot [ __ ] that's
what hot [ __ ] do they're just [ __ ]
they're in their own world that's great
what's up girl how you doing
what are you staring at me like go [ __ ]
yourself jump kick him out I don't give
a shot I say I said [ __ ] leave him
alone I'm an [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
she said kick me out in a respectful way
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Lewis is [ __ ] hilarious Lewis oh my
God this is always just Lewis yeah no
there is there's no settings to him
there's no different fun there's no
swerve Lewis is just Lewis what a stupid
the last time I seen the comic tree last
time I saw a comic treat women like this
was Patrice O'Neal honestly if you
really think about and by the way Lewis
is notoriously on the air just talks to
people like their [ __ ] like their
complete [ __ ] yeah I know we've done it
usually everyone works against digital
tells us about this he's like like he's
the nicest guy to work for I will say
it's just that once the mics are on it's
like I'm going to talk to you like your
gay [ __ ] the whole time that's the
only part of this job tall oh my God she
came on stage
I love him this is great
okay will you just kiss me already
forget all these games
what a douchebag
just forget everything what are we doing
here just let's [ __ ] go you and I
just [ __ ] get crazy tonight
I don't care about any of this
I don't no no don't look at her look at
me let's beat it let's
do we have a connection obviously okay
you're a little bit you're a firecracker
I can tell you have [ __ ] things going
on and you need a man you like to
[ __ ] just come she's falling in love
with him as you're watching this put you
down a little bit
well you've seen Amanda calm you down a
little bit where to get you going who
[ __ ] knows what's gonna happen with
you I will say
well it's one thing one thing
the way she likes him look at her face
of course look at her face why you have
approached the stage I will say it does
not support your case that you were not
being disrupted to the show
[Laughter]
because you've jumped up on stage and
now you're doing a dance and I think
it's great
I am going to okay so like the main
marry this woman just so you guys know
it's going to happen this is my type of
[ __ ] what's your name oh God damn it no
no no more
stop saying
you know what happened getting too much
attention dude you took the words right
out of my mouth virgin
her friend didn't like that her other
friend was getting too much attention
all the attention yeah all right look I
love you guys thank you very much
being here you're wonderful you're very
sexy as well thank you very much have
yourself a great night guys thank you
one more time for this crazy [ __ ]
come on
give it up for them how much money that
he [ __ ] both of them there we go wow I
think I handled that like a pro
that was
I like that you know Lewis is doing a
quick set and then leaving can you take
his [ __ ] coat off like no no of
course not in and out yeah look
I started comedy 17 years ago yo dog
yeah I gotta go do go rehab my name to
jiu jitsu bro I I got a real quick set
that I'm out and then I'm [ __ ] out
before people had cell phones if I would
if that would have happened 17 years ago
I would have [ __ ] clotheslined all of
those girls into the crowd and started
grounding pattern like that
wiping their blood on my face I'm like
let's go [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] Eat You
Alive you horse
you [ __ ] would take out your cell
phones and [ __ ] ruin my life you
[ __ ] traitors
I thought that was [ __ ] great bro
they [ __ ] now that's a real ass dude
um this is pretty much how I would if
you told me he got heckled by two
[ __ ] it's kind of how I would have
pictured it playing out yeah